herr schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live bei uns heute dieses thema die
steigende zahl der schweren corona
verläufe in bayern und thüringen wo
viele intensivstationen schon fast voll
sind was wenn da kein bett mehr frei ist
und wir wollen darüber sprechen mit drei
menschen die stellvertretend für all die
stehen die aktuell alles dafür tun dass
so viele wie möglich natürlich behandelt
werden können wir haben uns eingeladen
dr christoph spinner er ist der pandemie
beauftragte am klinikum rechts der isar
in münchen
benjamin petz leiter der notaufnahme des
klinikums in mühldorf und professor
michael bauer von der universitätsklinik
in jena und wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habe dann schreibt sie
jederzeit natürlich in den stream oder
direkt an die jetzt eingeblendete mail
adresse und die zahl der gemeldeten
kroner neuinfektionen die steigt im
ganzen land und einige bundesländer
reagieren darauf so zb hat thüringen das
kabinett heute eine zweig für viele
teile des öffentlichen lebens
beschlossen die soll auch noch von den
kommunen diese woche umgesetzt werden in
bayern gilt zweig schon seit gestern das
sind also zwei bundesländer die ganz
aktuell mit steigendem corona zahlen und
immer weniger freien betten kämpfen und
einen überblick über die aktuellen
zahlen und das geschehen gibt jetzt
erstmal christoph wiese
kliniken wieder am limit immer mehr
häuser sind ausgelastet weil jeden tag
neue corona erkrankte eingeliefert
werden die bundesweite hospitalisierung
since it ends liegt inzwischen bei 4,86
tendenz steigend sie gibt an wie viele
menschen pro 100.000 einwohner innen
innerhalb einer woche wegen corona ins
krankenhaus mussten der bisherige
höchstwert lag im dezember 2020 bei mehr
als 15 auch die zahl der kauffälle die
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen steigt aktuell sind es
3266 corona patientinnen auf den
intensivstationen
höchststand anfang januar mit
die freien betten auch für andere
operationen werden damit immer knapp
haben insgesamt stehen in deutschland
rund 22.200 intensivbetten zur verfügung
frei sind davon aktuell nur noch knapp
2500 oder 11 prozent
und in einigen regionen ist die lage
noch deutlich angespannter
besonders im süden in bayern etwa sind
nur noch rund neun prozent der
intensivbetten frei mehr als ein viertel
der intensivpatienten im freistaat ist
dann cupid 19 erkrankt
wir sprechen jetzt mit dr christoph
spinner er steht für uns live in der
korona station am klinikum rechts der
isar in münchen und nahm spinner
schon guthaben von jung wie ist denn die
lage heute abend jetzt auf ihrer station
in ihrem klinikum da wo sie gerade sind
in den letzten tagen verändert sich die
situation nahezu täglich dynamisch wir
nehmen jeden tag mindestens fünf bis
zehn patienten patienten auf die wir
sichten diagnostizieren und versorgen
müssen nahezu ein drittel unserer
intensivstationen ist bereits mit cupid
patientinnen belegt und wir erwarten
insbesondere ob der täglich steigenden
incidents werte in den nächsten tagen
noch deutlich steigende patientenzahlen
das bedeutet an der stelle auch wir
müssen die zur verfügung stehenden
ressourcen in der intensiv medizin aber
auch auf dem normalen stationen zwischen
koito nicht kurve patientinnen verteilen
denn alle haben das gleiche recht auf
eine adäquate und hochwertige
medizinische versorgung
und wir haben gleich viele fragen ganz
sicher auch als auch aus dem streamen
die wir miteinander besprechen können
aber zunächst wollen wir uns mal einen
beitrag anschauen über den alltag bei
ihnen im klinikum den hat meine kollegin
aus münchen sibylle bassler für uns
gemacht
es ist stress purer stress für niklas
schneider ein notruf erreicht den
oberarzt der münchner intensivstation
ich habe die leitstelle grad gut
belegung
69 jahre alt der alltägliche wahnsinn in
diesen tagen der pandemie ein ko-sieg
patient braucht dringend ein intensiv
bett alle kliniken lehnten ihn bisher ab
das problem ist der notarzt steht jetzt
draußen irgendwo mit dem patienten recht
im notarztwagen und muss irgendwie
klinik anfahren und die leitstelle
suchten es gibt im augenblick in münchen
kein freies kowitz intensiv wird mehr
auch auf seiner station sind alle betten
belegt schneide und sein team müssen
jetzt entscheiden wir kommen kann wer
nicht eine schwere entscheidung mit der
sie dann leben müssen in einer gewissen
form reagieren wir auch jetzt schon
jetzt ganz viele betten frei hätten dann
können wir auch sagen so ein patient wie
eben angemeldet wurde durch die
leitstelle den können wir
sicherheitshalber auf der
intensivstation nehmen
wir haben gerade ihren kollegen dr
schneider im beitrag gehört in einer
gewissen weise so sagte er reagieren sie
jetzt im moment schon auch was machen
sie denn wenn jetzt noch jemand kommt
und dann ist da einfach kein bett mehr
frei was passiert in so einer situation
in den letzten tagen war es häufiger der
fall dass keines der münchner
krankenhäuser insbesondere nicht der
große super maximalversorger also die
kliniken die das gesamte spektrum der
medizin anbieten können kein freies bett
mehr für die versorgung von patientinnen
hatten und gleichzeitig wird auch die
lage für die nicht kurve patientinnen
immer schwieriger denn gerade die
intensiv kapazität ist knapp wir sind
jeden tag gefordert diese ressourcen
zwischen kurve tunichtgut patientinnen
zu neu zu priorisieren neu zu verteilen
und natürlich müssen die notärztin
notärzte die draußen den menschen zu
hause in der akuten notfall situation
helfen eine lösung anbieten und wir sind
in der klinik genauso wie in anderen
münchnern häusern natürlich darum bemüht
betten zur verfügung zu stellen das
bedeutet aber jetzt ganz konkret dass
wir unseren regelbetrieb einschränken
müssen dass wir beginnen müssen
aufschiebbare operationen ambulante
kleinere eingriffe zu verschieben und
wir sehen mit sorge die entwicklung der
steigenden fallzahlen denn das kann auch
bedeuten dass auch größere eingriffe
wieder verschoben werden müssen um genug
kapazität für die akutbehandlung von
corvitum nicht kurve patientinnen
anzubieten die notfallversorgung in
münchen ist spürbar beeinträchtigt durch
diese situation und unabhängig von kogit
auch herzinfarkte und schlaganfälle
müssen weiter versorgt werden können ich
glaube dass beantwortet auch schon die
erste frage die hier sehe bei youtube
also ob wichtige geplante op es bereits
verschoben werden aufgrund der korona
lage das haben sie gerade beantwortet
aber was bedeutet das denn jetzt zb für
diese geplanten operation nicht nebenan
das sind ja auch dann nicht irgendwelche
operation das werden wichtige dinge sein
ob am herzen oder anderswo wie
priorisiert man da bei diesen auch dann
natürlich doch so wichtigen geplanten
operation wie machen sie das gerade
gerade in einem derart großen haus wir
uns als universitätsklinik werden
hochspezialisierte
eingriffe gefordert sowohl operationen
als auch interventionen also nicht
operative eingriffe wir sind der lage
hoch qualitative medizin für kündigt
google patientinnen anzubieten das macht
die situation aber noch schwieriger denn
in einer situation wie die ressourcen
lang ist längst knapp sind und das ist
bereits der fall müssen wir jetzt die
eingriffe die am ehesten noch ohne
schaden für den patienten um einige
wochen aufschiebbar sind auch
aufschieben das bedeutet ganz konkret
dass wir bereits begonnen haben
ambulante eingriffe auf unbestimmte zeit
zu verschieben
und wie es also wie ist das jetzt auch
gerade was wäre ihrer meinung nach also
jetzt wirklich auch ganz wichtig zu tun
wir haben gehört sie haben seit montag
in bayern gibt es jetzt diese sogenannte
zweig regel aber das wird ja noch eine
weile dauern bis da vielleicht sich
auswirkungen zeigen also was würde ihnen
denn jetzt ganz konkret akut helfen
die große schwierigkeit liegt er bereits
darin dass wir schon heute mehr die
patientinnen haben als wir in der region
oberbayern und der landeshauptstadt
versorgen können deswegen sind viele
kliniken auch nicht mehr versorgungs
bereit sie hatten das in beitrag gezeigt
es kommt durch die leitstelle zu
sogenannten zwangs belegt denn natürlich
werden wir alles erdenkliche tun dass
wir jedem menschen der sich in akuter
not befindet auch hilfe anbieten können
das bedeutet aber jetzt auch mit
verkündung des katastrophenfalls sind
wir gezwungen die eingriffe die in
irgendeiner art und weise mit möglichst
geringer gefahr für menschen
verschiebbar sind zu verschieben dass
wir genug kapazitäten auf den normalen
intensivstationen gewinnen können um
akut patientinnen vor allem im bereich
cupid und mit anderen lebensgefährlichen
oder ganz akuten erkrankungen versorgen
zu können
ostern ist mittelfristig eine
möglichkeit deswegen hat die
staatsregierung ja auch die maßnahme
ergriffen das bus der impfungen in
bayern verfügbar sind dieser effekt wird
sich aber erst in wochen bemerkbar
machen akut würde uns tatsächlich im
moment nur kontakt beschränkungen helfen
um die im moment teilweise
unkontrollierten infektionsketten
unterbrechen zu können denn das ist die
einzige möglichkeit um die
neuinfektionen und damit auch die neue
patienten auf den kliniken ganz akute
reduzieren zu können
und sagen sie wir schaffen sie das wir
leisten sie das im moment weil ich
glaube sie sind ja jetzt nicht plötzlich
auf einmal viel mehr personal geworden
sondern es ist eher das gegenteil der
fall oder
ja sie haben es gesagt im gegenteil wir
haben in den letzten zwölf monaten im
bereich aller münchner kliniken etwa
jedes fünfte intensiv mit verloren weil
nicht mehr genug pflegepersonal für den
betrieb dieser betten zur verfügung
steht die belastung für das gesamte
medizinische personal aber insbesondere
die pflegenden in den letzten monaten
der pandemie ist besonders
herausforderungs voller die ressourcen
werden immer knapper die zur verfügung
stehenden pflegen personen immer weniger
und gleichzeitig sehen wir uns mit
deutlich steigenden patientenzahlen
konfrontiert das heißt auch die
herausforderung wird jeden tag größer
eine frage noch zum schluss bei uns aus
dem stream homo pyros auf youtube möchte
wissen wie es das verhältnis von
geimpften ungeimpften patienten
patientinnen mit co wird auf der
intensivstation bei ihnen
das kann ich ganz klar beantworten weit
über drei viertel aller patientinnen bei
uns auf den normalen intensivstationen
sind umgehend das heißt es handelt sich
um vollständig vermeidbare schwere
verläufe der gofit 19 erkrankungen wir
sehen in den letzten tagen und wochen
fallen mit den steigenden
infektionszahlen natürlich auch im
durchbrüche und ihm versagen aber
überwiegend bei menschen die chronische
erkrankungen haben so dass die impfung
nicht so gut wirkt oder die älter sind
und oder chronische erkrankungen haben
und deren grund impfung über sechs
monate zurückliegt deswegen kommt gerade
für den menschen mit höherem lebensalter
sprich jenseits der sechzig und
chronischen erkrankung den musterungen
so viel zusätzlichen nutzen so viel
zusätzlicher nutzen zu denn die
musterung reduziert die
wahrscheinlichkeit der symptomatischen
erkrankungs infektion noch einmal über
95 prozent
vielen dank herr dr spinner an dieser
stelle nach münchen danke für den moment
ich danke ebenfalls jungen alles gute
danke das wünsche ich auch denn wir
haben nicht nur in münchen in der stadt
diese situation sondern ganz
angesprochenen ganz bayern ist die lage
also sehr sehr schwierig deswegen wollen
wir gleich auf sprechen mit benjamin
petz er ist der leiter der notaufnahme
des klinikums in mühldorf in bayern und
er entscheidet also darüber guten abend
der weg schon guten namen guten abend
sie entscheiden darüber ganz
grundsätzlich klar job wer also in der
notaufnahme wohin kommt und jetzt hören
wir beispielsweise von unserem
nachbarland in österreich in salzburg da
steht bereits die krankenhausversorgung
so auf der kippe dass da jetzt ein trias
team gebildet werden soll
zusammengestellt werden soll das
bedeutet das also im krankenhaus
priorisiert werden muss wem zuerst
geholfen wird herbedes wie weit sind sie
denn da noch von entfernt in mühldorf in
bayern von so einer situation
ja hallo schon gut haben erst mal ich
denke wir sind davon nicht mehr weit
entfernt
wir haben jetzt die glückliche situation
seit gestern nachmittag dass mir die
notaufnahme zumindest in zwei
notaufnahme uns teilen konnten das heißt
wir werden wieder die patienten bei der
aufnahme sichten einschätzen und dann
auch anhand von ihrem fact status in
zwei separate aufgebauten motoren
versorgen können das bedeutet natürlich
einen extremen personellen aufwand
sowohl ärztlich pflegerisch und
logistisch ja wo die leute oder wo wir
jetzt allmählich an die grenzen kommen
das thema triage war auch bei uns in der
klinik die letzten 12 wochen immer thema
und man ist sich sicher man wird in auf
diese entscheidung oder in diese
entscheidungssituation ein gewisses
gremium zu kommen oder aufstoßen sie
sprechen es an also das könnte auf sie
zukommen noch ist es nicht soweit ich
möchte trotzdem direkt dazu der frage
von christine häbe bei youtube im stream
aufgreifen also sie fragt jetzt nach der
trias aber ich glaube es lässt sich auch
eben auf jeden fall gut anwenden sie
fragt nach welchen kriterien wird bei
der triage entschieden spielt irgendwann
der impfstatus eine rolle ungeimpfte
werden abgewiesen weil sie eventuell
schlechtere genesungschancen haben als
geimpfte also ob das so ist möchte
christina hierbei gerne wissen
nein also das ist bei uns definitiv
nicht an der debatte man muss viele
aspekte beim patienten
damit der einspielen lassen alte
gebrechlichkeit vor diagnosen und auch
natürlich auch wie zuvor der mutmaßliche
patientenwille oder das gespräch mit den
angehörigen
es gibt ja auch die patienten die
chronische vorerkrankungen haben ein
gewisses leben sollte haben wo dann im
endeffekt die gesamtkonstellation
sich vielleicht auch frühzeitig gegen
eine intensivtherapie dazu entschieden
wird der impfstatus hatte spielte
allerdings keine rolle bei ihnen war das
auch meiner meinung nicht geben bei
ihnen wurde heute die dritte kurve
station eröffnet wenn ich da richtig
informiert bin und auch die zweite
corona notaufnahme ist das richtig das
ist richtig also wir haben heute die
dritte normalstation leer geräumt oder
mit normal patienten was vorher die
unfallchirurgen neurochirurgie war wurde
heute zu einer verdacht kurz station das
heißt alle patienten wo man auch keinen
eindeutigen befund haben oder ihn auch
symptomatisch sind aber der test aktuell
negatives werden auch heute nachmittag
auf der station aufgenommen zusätzlich
zwei vollumfängliche kurbelt normalen
stationen ich habe das ja dr spinne auch
gerade schon gefragt sind sie haben sie
denn jetzt plötzlich mehr personal für
so etwas zur verfügung oder wenn nicht
wie machen sie das
personal haben wir genauso wie den
rechts der isar weniger wie mir im
vergleich zu vor einem jahr
auch die
krankheitsrate bei den mitarbeitern oder
auch die komik positiven befunde oder
quarantäne zeiten sind natürlich auch im
personal da
wird speziell für die notaufnahme
haben nur die möglichkeit seit letzter
woche oder seit anfang dieser woche dass
mehr personal aus der op mannschaft
schlüssel zur verfügung haben weil da
auch elektiven operationen bereits
abgesagt wurden oder dass
operationschef der reduzierte
und wir halten sie das alle durch also
wie machen sie das und fühlen sie sich
auch vielleicht so ein bisschen da
allein in ihrer welt alleine auf der
station wo ist da so zugeht
ja also ich möchte auch ganz kurz die
möglichkeit ergreifen und meinem team
speziell einen riesen in diesen dank
aussprechen und die letzten fast zwei
jahre mittlerweile es ist tatsächlich so
dass man das dass das wie eine kleine
familie sieht aus dem gleichen boot
jeder kämpft mit den gleichen sorgen
ängste sieht das gleiche hat die
gleichen befürchtungen was ist die
nächsten wochen das hilft natürlich aber
ja das ist aus meiner sicht das puzzle
aus frust an das zusehen wie jetzt
draußen entschieden wird wie draußen
gefeiert wird weil es mögliches draußen
als normaler bürger wieder eine volle
das fußball stadion zu gehen und wir
gehen in die arbeit und sehen im
endeffekt komplett andere bilder das ist
absolut und 2schneidig und für mich aus
meiner perspektive unter ist meiner
funktion der leitung in der notaufnahme
und nicht nachvollziehbar und
haben sie ja schon darüber gesprochen
gibt es einen plan b plan c wenn jetzt
noch mehr kranke kommen was ist da die
prognose
gibt es für mich momentan keine prognose
wir werden weiter die kuwait patienten
versorgen wir werden weiter die noch
nicht kurve kranken patienten versorgen
bis wir ein gewisses limit kommen und
dann im endeffekt ja entschieden werden
muss mit nachbar klinik weitere
verlegungen wir haben in der letzten
woche patienten dass ich glaube das
weiteste war nach würzburg verlegt und
wieder intensiv kapazitäten zu haben das
wird einfach eine durchhalteparole sein
und
heftige winter werden
vielen dank benjamin fest dass sie da
ihre erfahrungen mit uns geteilt haben
heute abend uns da ihre zeit geschenkt
haben vielen dank an dieser stelle
sollte schon abend
und nicht nur in bayern wir haben ja
gerade zwei beispiele aus bayern gehört
sondern auch in thüringen sind mit am
wenigsten menschen vollständig geimpft
und hier steigen auch die korona zahlen
und gleichzeitig werden die betten die
intensivbetten in den krankenhäusern
dort immer weniger wenn dazu eine
übersicht einen beitrag von christoph
wiese
viele corona neuinfektionen viele
erkrankte auf den intensivstationen
thüringen zählt zu den bundesländern in
denen die korona lage besonders
angespannt ist die inzidenz steigt
aktuell liegt die zahl bei fünf 146,1
der dritthöchste wert bundesweit
intensivbetten gibt es in thüringen
633 frei sind aber nur noch 81 oder 12,8
prozent mit 19 patientinnen sind 181
betten belegt
28,6 prozent
in keinem anderen bundesland ist der
anteil der kogit patientinnen so hoch
wie hier und prognosen gehen davon aus
dass der wert in den nächsten wochen
noch deutlich steigt
und dazu können wir jetzt fragen
professor dr michael bauer von der
universitätsklinik in jena und außerdem
sind sie auch zuständig für die
intensivbetten in ganz thüringen also um
diese zu koordinieren schönen guten
abend herr bauer
guten morgen frau jung herr professor
bauer wie ist denn die lage stand jetzt
wie viele intensivbetten sind denn bei
ihnen noch frei
bei uns sind seit wochen eine
intensivbetten frei wir machen betten
frei wenn ein patient auf die
intensivstation muss aber alle betten
sind wenn sie verfügbar sind und
betrieben werden können belegt wir sind
auch schon in der situation dass wir
tatsächlich den ganzen tag
koordinieren telefonieren wie wir
patienten in thürigen zentral verteilen
und auch im gespräch mit anderen
bundesländern also wir werden wieder wie
um den jahreswechsel sehr bald in die
situation kommen dass wir patienten aus
thüringen andere bundesländer verlegen
werden müssen und wenn sie davon
sprechen betten werden frei gemacht hat
auch die frage an sie wie machen sie das
wenn wir eigentlich hören es sind ja gar
keine frei wie schaffen sie das ja es
gibt sogenannte step down bitten in der
medien kerr betten wir werden dann immer
die patienten die am besten sind die
nicht mehr beatmet sind die von der
kreislauf funktion so weit stabil sind
dass sie nur noch überwacht werden
müssen im überwachungsbereich
verlegen und dann halt entsprechend
schwerer kranke auf die intensivstation
aufgeben also ich höre sie priorisieren
ja jetzt schon irgendwie ein bisschen
ihre hilfeleistungen und auch nach
kapazität und arbeitskraft kann man da
jetzt schon von der tria sprechen der
sogenannten oder ist das noch zu früh
eine echten prix ars situation sind wir
nicht ich befürchte allerdings dass ich
mit meiner 30-jährigen berufserfahrungen
der intensivmedizin das zum ersten mal
erleben werden könnte es ist aktuell so
dass wir in der intensivmedizin
in einer exponentiellen
wachstums funktion bei den belegten
betten sind wir nehmen jeden tag in
thüringen der größenordnung zwischen
sechs und zehn patienten auf und die
verweildauer ist zwischen zwei und drei
wochen dann muss man einfach
extrapolieren und man sieht also auch
was wir in den letzten tagen gesehen
haben die wachstums funktion ist
bedrohlich und wir haben aktuell ein
drittel aller intensivbetten den
thüringen mit kobe patienten belegt die
wir betreiben können das heißt aber auch
es gibt regionen wo 70 bis 80 prozent
der patienten corona patienten sind auf
der intensivstation wir übernehmen
aus ganz thüringen patienten wir wollten
heute einen patienten aus meinigen
übernehmen konnten allerdings nicht mit
dem hubschrauber die verlegung
organisieren weil nebel thüringer wald
war also es sind schon wirklich auch
weite strecken die wir hier zurücklegen
müssen um die patienten adäquat zu
versorgen
vielleicht muss ich hier auch mal kurz
aufgreifen es gibt ein paar im stream
die behaupten dass viele patienten auch
aus dem ausland behandelt würden könnten
sie das vielleicht mal aufgreifen und
uns vielleicht mal berichten wer also
bei ihnen dort auf stationen liegt in
den intensivbetten da gab es auch
übrigens die frage wie alt die
patientinnen und patienten denn sein
also sie fragen kann ich sehr gerne
beantworten also es gab eine anfrage vor
etwa zehn tagen
anders rk ii inwieweit wir bereit sind
patienten aus rumänien oder
aus slowenien zu übernehmen ich habe für
thüringen hier absagen müssen obwohl ich
der meinung bin dass wir gut beraten
sind solidarisch zu handeln wir haben
eben gehört das aus bayern patienten
nach italien gehen wir kommen langsam
aber sicher in die situation dass wir
solche ausgleichsmechanismen nutzen
müssen und solidarität funktioniert
immer in beide richtungen das lka hat
aber thüringen auch in anbetracht der
belegungssituation auf den thüringer
intensivstationen nicht als zielort
gewählt die situation ist in den alten
bundesländern und insbesondere auch im
nordwesten der republik noch entspannter
und diese kliniken haben hier primär
auch patienten aus rumänien übernommen
das ging auch über
überschaubare anzahl von patienten also
wir sprechen hier von 18 patienten
aber zum beispiel hilft die bundeswehr
in anderen europäischen ländern bereits
gerade in osteuropa auf den
intensivstationen aus auch wir waren um
den jahreswechsel dankbar um die die
hilfe durch die bundeswehr auch auf
unserer intensivstation und es ist
durchaus denkbar dass wir auch auf diese
ressource wieder zurückgreifen müssen
bezüglich des alters der patienten kann
ich ihnen sagen dass das maximum der
patienten das jetzt bei uns auf der
intensivstation
behandelt wird im zeitfenster im
altersbereich 50 bis 70 jahre alt ist
wir haben eine 29 jährige patientin auf
station und wir haben einen 83 jährigen
patienten auf der station
aber das gros der patienten ist zwischen
50 und 70 und auch die frage an sie dich
schon an die kollegen aus bayern
gestellt habe weil das kam auch immer
wieder in den fragen wie sieht es denn
da aus mit dem verhältnis geimpft nicht
geimpft jetzt ist auch die impfquote in
thüringen eher niedrig wie sieht das der
aus sie waren heute morgen noch bei der
visite
ja also heute morgen bei der visite habe
ich zwei geimpfte patienten mit
durchbrüchen gesehen und 15 nicht
geimpfte patienten
ich kann aber auch noch mal was er
später gesagt hat nur bestätigen die
verläufe bei impf durchbrüchen sind
milder bezüglich der lungen beteiligung
als bei ungeimpften und es ist eine
frage der wahrscheinlichkeiten sind
patienten mit
schweren begleiterkrankungen
die hier eine nur unzureichende im kant
wort aufbauen können zum beispiel
patienten mit bösartigen tumoren gerade
solche des blutbildenden systems oder
patienten mit einer immunsuppression wir
haben patienten die
zum beispiel organ transplantiert sind
dann kann aufgrund der immunsuppression
wie im antwort nicht in der weise
ausfallen ich habe in meiner ganzen
erfahrung bei über 370 patienten die wir
auf der intensivstation mittlerweile
behandelt haben hier im klinikum noch
keinen in ansonsten gesunden patienten
gesehen der nach einer impfung einen
durchbruch mit blumen versagen wie gehen
sie und ihr team damit um wenn jetzt
quasi in eine situation kommen wo der
großteil der menschen in den
intensivbetten nicht geimpft das macht
das frust bei den kolleginnen und
kollegen wie ja wie geht es ihnen damit
ja man muss als
pflegekraft als mediziner in der lage
seien hier auch sich frei zu machen von
weltanschaulichen betrachtungen es ist
trotzdem ermüdend und vor allen dingen
ist es halt auch ethisch so wie sich die
situation auch in thüringen entwickelt
eine echte zwickmühle wie man in den
nächsten tagen und wochen mit der
situation umgeht
der deutsche ethikrat hat unter anderem
auch schon durchaus solche erwägungen
wie den impfstatus
hier auch einfließen zu lassen in die
entscheidungen durchaus diskutiert gott
sei dank sind wir noch nicht in dieser
situation noch können wir über ausgleich
mit anderen bundesländern nachdenken nur
bei ungebremster entwicklung und
deswegen hoffe ich sehr dass die 2g
regel auch konsequent umgesetzt und
kontrolliert wird ohne dass wir diese
welle brechen werden wir in eine
situation kommen wo wir ganz
schwierige entscheidungen treffen müssen
die ich in 30 jahren intensiv medizin
und nicht treffen musste
ulrike bei youtube fragt sie gerade
angesprochen die zweijährige eureka bei
youtube fragt sich welche maßnahmen
wären notwendig um dieser entwicklung
entgegenzuwirken reicht zweig zweig plus
denn aus und da auch noch anschließend
auch die frage von dennis lange der sich
fragt was können denn bürger tun ganz
konkret was für maßnahmen damit sie der
krankenhaus belegschaft helfen können
also ganz konkret der wissenschaftliche
beirat der landesregierung in thüringen
empfiehlt zweig plus maske so steht es
auch in der verordnung des landes drin
das heißt auch geimpfte können den virus
weiter geben also ich glaube dass wir
uns an zweig plus maske
nun müssen für die nächsten wochen wir
sollten große veranstaltungen die zu
super spreading events werden können wir
kennen das aus ischgl wir kennen es aus
heinsberg aus gangelt
karnevalsveranstaltungen
können zu absoluten super spreading
events werden also auch da sollte man
einfach mit einer gewissen
[Musik]
bereitschaft auch zur reduktion solcher
events und ereignisse
sich wappnen und ist nochmal der appell
ist es ganz klar impfung ist der weg aus
der krise auch wir haben
limits bei der verfügbarkeit von
impfstoff wir haben mehr personal in den
kliniken die geimpft gepustet werden
möchten weil sie jeden tag mit solchen
patienten zu tun haben als wir momentan
im slots anbieten können für unser
personal daran arbeiten wir mit
hochdruck aber impfen ist der weg aus
der krise und bis dahin reduktion der
kontakte zweig und maske das sind die
akuten möglichkeiten die wir haben und
natürlich jetzt auch für uns akut der
bedarf auf die solidarität anderer
bundesländer auch zurückzugreifen
und sie haben natürlich jetzt als die
menschen die da unmittelbar ganz nah
dran sind nicht die möglichkeit sich da
irgendwie zurück zu ziehen sind im
ganzen jahr unmittelbar ausgesetzt wie
schaffen sie es denn ihre belegschaft da
ehrlicherweise auch noch zu motivieren
jetzt im zweiten corona ja da wirklich
dabei zu bleiben
ja also wir sind in der glücklichen
situation zwei psychologinnen auf der
station zu haben die ganz
engagiert sich um die belange der
angehörigen unserer patienten kümmern
aber auch um das personal das ist eine
ganz ganz wesentliche hilfe
dass man wenn man überlastet ist sich an
professionelle hilfe wenden kann wir
haben auf der anderen seite auch eine
zunahme des krankenstands im
pflegerischen im ärztlichen personal das
ist eine extreme belastung situation die
jetzt schon so lange anhält und die
verlässliche
einhaltung von bestimmten spielregeln
auch die
ja die
möglichkeit die pflegepersonal
untergrenzen verordnung einzuhalten auch
wenn das wehtut die betten zu sperren
und dann halt ganz konsequent zwischen
kliniken patienten zu verteilen das sind
aktuell wirklich wichtige strategien wie
das schlimmste verhindern ich schaue
noch mal in die kommentare es gibt sich
ja auch noch einige fragen sie ich hatte
auch eine 1 kommentar gesehen der ist
mir vorhin durchgerutscht da auf jeden
fall sprach man ihnen dank aus allen
medizinischen kräften das will ich
natürlich weiter geben auch wenn ich
leider nicht mehr finde wer ist
geschrieben hat aber jetzt nochmal zu
euren meinungen und fragen es gab hier
noch ein bisschen allgemeine
fragen und ich versuche mich hier durch
also es gab auch noch mal hier nachfrage
von civ player bei youtube der sich
fragt warum kommen unsere intensivbetten
eigentlich an die belastungsgrenze bei
einer inzidenz zwischen 250 und 300
während in großbritannien seit wochen
die inzidenz um die 400 liegt und ich
dort nichts von trias höhere also warum
sind bei uns denn die intensivbetten an
der belastungsgrenze
also ich kann ihnen ganz sicher sagen
und ich habe sehr gute einblicke ins
englische system mein bruder ist seit
über 20 jahren in england als arzt tätig
ich habe gute freunde in london
sie kommen in england überhaupt nicht im
altersklassen in denen bei uns noch
intensivbehandlung
selbstverständlich erfolgt auf eine
intensivstation in finnland die
wartezeiten in england auf eine
operation zum beispiel auf eine planbare
operation werden momentan im
täglichen zunehmendem maße nach hinten
ganz extrem in london können sie unter
umständen 12 14 16 stunden in einem
rettungswagen warten bevor sie in ein
krankenhaus kommen also zu glauben dass
in england wo es altersgrenzen gibt wann
noch eine dialysebehandlung begonnen
wird etc
dass dort nicht reagiert wird ist
einfach unwissenheit oder mangelnde
kommunikation ecmo therapien werden dort
oft schon bei altersklasse 45 oder 50
jahre abgebrochen das heißt nur bis 45
oder 50 können sie in einzelnen kliniken
diese therapien kriegen in deutschland
können sie auch mit höherem alter noch
mit einer maximalen therapie rechnen es
ist wirklich nicht so dass es in england
keine tricks sondern in england ist die
triage ein täglicher standard
es gibt noch mehr fragen jessica medi
fragt wie ist es möglich dass wir höhere
zahlen mit impfungen haben als letztes
jahr ohne impfung
ja das ist ganz einfach eine frage der
statistik wenn sie in dem maße wie wir
aktuell kontakte haben und da können
sich jeder selbst an die eigene nase
fassen und sich auch mal
gucken wir haben vor bisher um die
gleiche zeit viel viel weniger
kontakte gehabt als wir es dieses jahr
wenn sie jetzt in eine bahn sich setzen
in dem ece diese vollen züge die gab es
voriges jahr um diese zeit nicht wenn
sie gucken wie man sich trifft in
restaurants zusammentrifft wie man in
den entsprechenden sozialen kontakten
wieder normal unterwegs ist dann ist das
ein ganz großer verdienst der impfung
also man sollte das auch nicht
kleinreden und sie sehen es halt auch
wenn sie die individuelle korrelation
zwischen impfquote und belegung der
intensivstationen innerhalb deutscher
bundesländer oder auch zwischen
europäischen ländern das haben wir in
ihrem bericht ja auch gesehen
vergleichen dann ist der zusammenhang
eindeutig
ich habe hier noch zwei fragen kann ich
auch gut zusammenfassen hier wird so ein
bisschen die frage gestellt was es mit
den bundeswehrkrankenhäusern und was es
auch mit zivildienstleistenden ob die
nicht als helfer herangezogen werden
könnten um sie zu unterstützen
ja wir mobilisieren
aktuell auch wieder mann und maus man
darf das system nur nicht
überstrapazieren wir können nicht
einfach sagen durch mehr personal das
wir irgendwo her mobilisieren können wir
die komplette einschränkung dieser
infektion ersetzen sie dürfen auch nicht
vergessen wer bei uns auf der
intensivstation behandelt wird der hat
ein ganz hohes maß an
leid und an belastung auch zu ertragen
wir haben eine sterblichkeit in der
größenordnung von 30 bis 50 prozent bei
diesen patienten viele patienten die
nach wochen oder monaten auf der
intensivstation
nach hause gehen sind nicht mehr die
alten sie haben von longkou lied gehört
sicher alle es gibt persistierendem
probleme es gibt einfach schwere folge
zustände man sollte nicht glauben dass
die infektion wenn man nur genug
intensivbetten hat etwas ist was man
einfach so zur kenntnis nehmen kann das
ist eine sehr große belastung für die
patienten und es ist mitnichten so dass
das also spurlos an einem vorbei geht
wenn man die erkrankung überlebt
vielen dank herr professor dr bauer für
diese ganzen einblicke und auch für die
einschätzung und dass sie sich heute
abend zeit genommen haben ich glaube da
muss man besonders verdanken in dieser
zeit wo er für sie wirklich auch
freizeit sehr knapp das vielen dank
dafür
schönen abend danke
und vielen dank für eure aufmerksamkeit
und eure kommentare und fragen wie ich
hoffe ich konnte so viele wie möglich
davon jetzt hier einbringen und dann
haben wir von unseren experten dazu auch
viele antworten gehört und wir behalten
das thema für euch weiter im blick in
den nächsten tagen und das dahin danke
und tschüss
[Musik]